[Música]
Ucrania rechazó la propuesta de alto al
fuego de 36 horas hecha por el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin tras un
pedido Expreso hecho por el patriarca de
la iglesia ortodoxa rusa kiev exigió que
las tropas rusas abandonen el territorio
ucraniano para poder Establecer un alto
al fuego
en Israel cientos de personas Se tomaron
las calles de diferentes ciudades del
país en rechazo al plan propuesto por el
gobierno del Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu para reformar la Corte Suprema
del país que También incluye un nuevo
comité de revisión para las nominaciones
a ese tribunal
y los restos del Papa Benedicto 16 ya
descansan en las grutas del Vaticano
Después de varios días de estar en
cámara ardiente el Papa Francisco
presidió el funeral en el que sacerdotes
y también el público en general le
dieron su último adiós al retirado
pontífice Tenemos reporte desde ciudad
del Vaticano
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en el
continente europeo Ucrania rechazó la
propuesta de Ceci al fuego hecha por un
espacio de 36 horas presentada por el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin quien
ofreció esta tregua con motivo de la
Navidad ortodoxa que es celebrada el 7
de enero el gobierno del presidente
ucraniano que argumentó que la única
forma para que haya un cese al fuego es
por medio del retiro de las tropas rusas
en las zonas ocupadas de Ucrania la
decisión Del kremlin de proponer esta
tregua tuvo lugar después de que el
patriarca quiril el líder máximo de la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa pidiera una tregua
navideña previamente también el
presidente
turcoan pidió a su homólogo ruso que
realizara este alto al fuego al tiempo
crítico que hablaría con el presidente
de Ucrania
en las próximas horas sobre la necesidad
establecer ese alto al fuego escuchemos
en su momento también hablaré con el
presidente de Ucrania Bueno dime como
hice con Putin
en esta llamada discutiremos Cómo
podemos suavizar las relaciones entre
Rusia y Ucrania
también hablaremos sobre el corredor de
cereales
nos vamos ahora hasta Israel donde el
ministro de Justicia del nuevo gobierno
del Primer Ministro Benjamín netanyahu
presentó una propuesta de reforma
judicial que reduciría drásticamente El
poder del tribunal supremo impidiendo
que pueda ir en contra de las decisiones
del parlamento y del gobierno ante estos
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles para rechazar esta propuesta del
gobierno de extrema derecha y también
Mostrar su descontento por el
nombramiento del líder Ultra ortodoxo
como ministro de El gabinete
a una condena en su contra por fraude
fiscal el anuncio de la Reforma a la
justicia era ampliamente esperada desde
el bloque de partidos nacionalistas
religiosos cercanos al ministro o Primer
Ministro netanyahu
se trata de una reforma que podría
inclinar La balanza del poder en Israel
yarius levin ministro de Justicia el
nuevo gobierno de derecha israelí quiere
reducir fuertemente los poderes del
tribunal supremo con una cláusula de
anulación que permitiría la keneth
retrotraer una decisión del tribunal
supremo tras una votación el parlamento
estaría Entonces por encima del poder
judicial la falta de una constitución el
tribunal supremo israelí puede ahora
derogar las leyes que considere
contrarias a las leyes fundamentales del
país un poder demasiado importante para
el ministro de Justicia creo que no solo
la kenes y el gobierno derivan su poder
de la confianza pública sino también el
poder judicial la revolución judicial y
el hecho de que el poder judicial
interfiera cada vez más en las
decisiones del gobierno y en las
votaciones de la keneth han hecho que la
confianza del público en el poder
judicial haya caído a mínimos históricos
esto debilita El poder del gobierno y
perjudica a la democracia la reforma
llega en un momento en que el Primer
Ministro Benjamín netanyahu está siendo
juzgado por corrupción los especialistas
seña que esta cláusula de anulación
permitiría al parlamento votar a favor
de la inmunidad judicial de netanyahu a
impediría al tribunal supremo revocar
esta decisión la reforma también
pretende revisar el método de
nombramiento de los magistrados del
tribunal supremo designados por un panel
de jueces diputados y abogados ahora se
reforzaría el peso de los cargos electos
en el proceso y se cumplen ya 25 días
del inicio del bloqueo por parte de
activistas de azerbaiyán al corredor de
la chin la única vía de acceso terrestre
a la región de nacort no carabach el
gobierno armenio continuó haciendo
esfuerzos a nivel internacional para
garantizar el suministro de alimentos y
medicinas a esta región en donde Residen
cerca de 120.000 personas por lo que han
propuesto la creación de un puente aéreo
a través del aeropuerto de estepanaker
la ciudad más poblada de la región entre
tanto siguen también los
cuestionamientos a las fuerzas de paz de
Rusia encargadas de garantizar la
seguridad y la paz en esa zona por no
levantar el bloqueo
y en otros temas la Iglesia Católica sus
principales jerarcas y también sus
seguidores despidieron los restos del
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 tras varios
días de estar en cámara ardiente ahora
el cuerpo Descansa en las grutas del
Vaticano en donde como lo marca la
tradición reposan los restos de los
sumos pontífices Natalia Mendoza desde
ciudad del Vaticano nos da más
información sobre la jornada de hoy
escuchemos
en un ambiente de profunda devoción
50.000 fieles se congregaron en el
Vaticano para asistir al funeral del
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 este jueves la
misa presidida por el Papa Francisco
duro un poco más de una hora durante su
homilía Francisco rindió homenaje a su
predecesor habló de su sabiduría de su
delicadeza al final de la misa el
féretro fue trasladado a la cripta de la
Basílica de San Pedro para su entierro
en el interior del ataúd junto al cuerpo
de ratzinger se introdujeron las
medallas y monedas acuñadas durante su
pontificado también el llamado rollito
un breve texto con los actos más
destacados del Papa emérito finalmente
se procedió a la inhumación en la tumba
en la cual reposó Juan Pablo Segundo
antes de ser canonizado ser enterrado
allí fue una de las últimas voluntades
de Benedicto 16 el primer papa que
renunció a su cargo en seis siglos de
historia
y Mientras tanto en nuestro continente
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden visitará el próximo domingo por
primera vez la frontera común con México
para conocer de primera mano Cuál es la
situación migratoria en esa zona
Asimismo el presidente estadounidense
arribará a la Ciudad de México el lunes
9 de enero para sostener un encuentro
con su homólogo mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador para tratar temas
bilaterales de igual forma se espera que
el día miércoles arrive también a la
capital mexicana El Primer Ministro de
Canadá Justin para participar en una
cumbre de países norteamericanos para
tratar temas de competitividad seguridad
cambio climático migración diversidad y
también medio ambiente
el libro con las memorias del príncipe
Harry del Reino Unido será presentado a
nivel internacional pero desde ya
comienza a tener unas declaraciones
explosivas por sus revelaciones entre
las que expone por ejemplo una supuesta
agresión por parte de su hermano William
El príncipe de gales que dejó varias
heridas en la espalda el Duque de Sauces
también acusa a la casa de Windsor de
haber filtrado información sobre él y
sobre su esposa Meghan a la prensa
británica lo que amenaza compensar aún
más las relaciones con la corona
británica Andrés Meza Muñoz tiene los
detalles
es la más reciente de una serie de
declaraciones públicas sobre miembros de
la corona británica en extractos de su
próximo libro que fueron filtrados por
el periódico de Guardian el príncipe
Harry narra como fue agredido
físicamente por su hermano el próximo
rey de Reino Unido quien se habría
referido a su esposa Megan como una
persona difícil grosera y abrasiva me
agarró por el cuello rasgó mi collar y
me tiró al suelo aterricé en el plato
del perro que se partió debajo de mi
espalda los pedazos me cortaron la
discusión que Data de 2019 está plasmada
en las nuevas Memorias de Harry que
saldrán a la venta la próxima semana
espere el título del libro y Que traduce
repuesto proviene de un viejo dicho en
los círculos reales y que hace
referencia al segundo hijo visto como un
sustituto en caso de que algo llegue a
pasarle al primogénito segunda Guardian
el libro narra como el día del
nacimiento de Harry Eloy Rey Carlos III
mencionó que ahora Tenía un heredero y
un repuesto sin embargo en el adelanto
de una entrevista que será emitida el
fin de semana por la cadena TV el
príncipe dice que quiere recuperar a su
padre y a su hermano aunque no está
seguro de asistir a la coronación del
nuevo monarca en mayo muchas cosas
pueden pasar hasta entonces pero la
puerta está siempre abierta el balón
está en su terreno hay mucho que
discutir y realmente espero que estén
dispuestos a sentarse y hablar Harry
también menciona que no sabe si era
parte de la monarquía en el futuro acusa
a su familia de pasar información
perjudicial para él a la prensa y
subraya que permanecer en silencio como
suele hacer el Palacio ante casos
polémicos no mejora las cosas su libro
que según de Guardian relata escenas y
conversaciones intensamente privadas
podría ser igual de perturbador para la
familia Real Como lo fueron las
explosivas memorias de Diana publicadas
en 1992 Y con estas explosivas
declaraciones finalizamos este
informativo de France 24 más información
en France 24.com y en las redes sociales
siga con nosotros buenas tardes
[Música]